[Music]
variant identified
i beg your pardon on behalf of the time
variance authority i hereby arrest you
for crimes against the sacred timeline
hands up
you're coming with us
i'm sorry who's us
last chance variant
there are a vast number of marvel
television shows from the newest slate
of disney plus shows to the other
properties outside of the mcu and
regardless if they're tied to the mcu or
not there are plenty of good shows to
choose from so today we're gonna look at
the best marvel tv shows
[Music]
there are four arrows more dangerous
than that one for this list we've
included titles that have at least 10
reviews and ties were resolved by the
number of reviews for each title and
further by the quote average rating
marvel has dominated the big screen and
are now doing the same for television so
let's count down the best marvel tv
shows ranked by tomato meter
[Music]
number 10 cloak and dagger
tandy bowen and tyrone johnson come from
starkly different backgrounds each
growing up with a secret they never
dared to share with another soul tandy
watched as her family was destroyed by a
disastrous storm that uprooted her life
and when everything tyrone held close
was taken away life taught him to be
afraid starring olivia hull aubrey
joseph andrea roth and created by joe
pokoski critics say cloak and dagger
blends soapy drama with superhero grit
to create an exciting surprisingly
thoughtful addition to the genre even if
it falls prey to a certain amount of
narrative bloat
so
there we are
yeah
here we are
looks like a riley led me right to you
you really gonna try to shoot at me
again
no
fool me thrice
you little side piece though
i'm guessing she doesn't travel as light
as you
nope
she doesn't
i'm not letting you hold my life hostage
anymore
not my friends or my family you
understand listen you little
i'm not afraid of you anymore
but you yeah
you should be
you should be very
very
afraid you afraid
[Music]
number nine marvel's luke cage
this gritty action-packed drama follows
the evolution of luke cage a man with
super strength and unbreakable skin
caused by a sabotaged experiment after a
failed relationship with fellow
superhero jessica jones cage tries to
rebuild a quiet life in harlem new york
until he's pulled out of the shadows and
forced into a battle for his city along
the way cage can't avoid confronting his
past which he has worked hard to bury
starring mike coulter mahershala ali
rosario dawson and created by chio
hidari coker critics say an immersive
socially conscious narrative and a
confident charismatic lead performance
make marvel's luke cage a stellar
sampling of the new marvel netflix
universe
give us
the money
yo
i don't like your tune
excuse me you're being disrespectful
it's unnecessary
your weemus
what up
show the man what you famous for
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you want some
number eight the falcon and the winter
soldier
falcon and the winter soldier are a
mismatch duo who team up for a global
adventure that will test their survival
skills as well as their patients
starring anthony mackie sebastian stan
daniel broll and created by malcolm
spellman critics say packed with
blockbuster action and deft character
beats falcon in the winter soldier
proves itself worthy of captain
america's legacy with its globetrotting
intrigue mature social commentary and
the sparky rapport between stars anthony
mackie and sebastian stan
get your head down
[Music]
sharon bucky what's going on on your end
nothing all quiet
i'm sorry wait who are you captain
america
number seven marvel's modoc
while pursuing his dream of conquering
the world a megalomaniacal supervillain
runs his evil organization into the
ground starring melissa fumero amy
garcia and patton oswalt who created the
show with jordan blum critics say though
its tendency toward too muchness may
test some viewers patience slick stop
motion a killer voice cast and a
seemingly endless well of jokes made
modok an entertainingly chaotic
diversion
[Music]
what's that little thing
oh my god
you still can't use your mind
my dang shoulder
[Music]
number six legion
david haller is a troubled young man who
was diagnosed with schizophrenia as a
child
shoveled from one psychiatric
institution to the next in his early 30s
david meets and falls in love with a
beautiful and troubled fellow patient
named sid after a startling encounter
with her he must confront the shocking
possibility that the voices he hears and
the visions he sees may actually be real
with the help of sid and a team of
specialists who also possess unique and
extraordinary gifts ptolemy wallace and
carrie and carrie loudermilk david
unlocks a deeply suppressed truth he has
been haunted his entire life by a
malicious parasite of unimaginable power
starring dan stevens aubry plaza rachel
keller and created by noah hawley
critics say bold intelligent and
visually arresting legion is a
masterfully surreal and brilliantly
daring departure from traditional
superhero conceits
[Music]
remember
i was gonna let you go
number five wanda vision
living idealized suburban lives super
powered beings wanda and vision begin to
suspect that everything is not as it
seems starring elizabeth olsen paul
bettany tiana paris catherine hahn and
created by jack shafer critics say part
loving homage to tv history part
off-kilter mystery one division is a
wonderfully weird and strikingly bold
step into the small screen for the mcu
and a perfect showcase for elizabeth
olsen and paul bettany
i don't want it
what are you doing come on
[Music]
um
[Music]
there's more i want it all
[Music]
number four loki
loki the god of mischief steps out of
his brother's shadow to embark on an
adventure that takes place after the
events of avengers end game starring tom
hiddleston sophia demartino owen wilson
and created by michael waldron critics
say a delightful diversion from the mcu
as we know it loki successfully sees
star tom hiddleston leap from beloved
villain to endearing anti-hero with a
little help from owen wilson in a series
that's as off-kilter charming and
vaguely dangerous as the demigod himself
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
maybe he's lying
maybe he's not
the cost of getting this wrong
is too great fine
do it
kill me take your throne
stop
stop
number three hawkeye
clint barton and kate bishop shoot a few
arrows and try to avoid becoming the
target themselves starring jeremy renner
haley steinfeld vera farmiga alaqua cox
and created by jonathan igla and rhys
thomas critics say hawkeye starts slowly
but the street level action is a
refreshing change of pace for the mcu
and the chemistry between its leads
sparkles even when the plot lags
[Music]
number two marvel's daredevil
daredevil follows matt murdock attorney
by day and vigilante by night blinded in
an accident as a child murdoch uses his
heightened senses as daredevil to fight
crime on the streets of new york after
the sun goes down while murdoch's day
job requires him to believe in the
criminal justice system his alter ego
does not follow suit this leads him to
take the law into his own hands to
protect his hell's kitchen neighborhood
and the surrounding communities starring
charlie cox eldon henson deborah ann
wall vincent d'onofrio and created by
drew goddard critics say with tight
adherence to its source materials
history high production quality and a
no-nonsense dramatic flair daredevil
excels as an effective superhero origin
story a gritty procedural and an
exciting action-adventure
ugh
[Music]
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
marvel's the punisher
after exacting revenge on the people
responsible for the deaths of his wife
and children frank castle uncovers a
conspiracy that runs deeper than new
york's criminal underworld now known as
the punisher he must dig deep into the
conspiracy to discover the truth about
injustices that affect more than just
him and his family assisting the
vigilante in his quest to fight
criminals our best friend billy russo
who runs private military corporation
anvil and former nsa analyst micro who
shares common enemies with castle and
helps him as part of a so-called
marriage of convenience starring john
bernthal ben barnes amber rose riva and
created by steve lightfoot critics say a
rocky start can't keep the punisher from
pushing the boundaries of marvel's tv
universe with a fresh take on the comics
derived action thriller
i'm not your enemy
those photos
who paid for
try the internet
[Music]
i swear to god they made me do it man
yeah
did exactly what i wanted you to
marvel's jessica jones
a chronicle of the life of one of the
darker marvel characters the mysterious
jessica jones when a tragedy puts an end
to her short-lived career as a superhero
jessica settles in new york city there
she opens her own detective agency
called alias investigations which seems
to be called into cases involving people
who have special abilities suffering
from post-traumatic stress syndrome
jessica wants to do good but her primary
interest isn't in saving the world it's
saving her apartment and getting through
each day starring kristen ritter rachel
taylor ika darville david tennant and
created by melissa rosenberg critics say
jessica jones builds a multifaceted
drama around its engaging anti-hero
delivering what might be marvel's
strongest tv franchise to date
i know the drill i'm not gonna follow
him i just want to know where he is
i am not the enemy
[Music]
you can't follow him
i'm sorry about this
and before we get to number one here is
another honorable mention
marvel's agent carter
peggy carter is an unstoppable secret
agent for the strategic scientific
reserve dedicated to fighting new atomic
threats that have emerged after world
war ii after working in new york peggy
heads across the country to la for her
most dangerous assignment yet as peggy
explores the bright lights of hollywood
and discovers new friends and perhaps a
new romance a sinister threat emerges
that could impact everyone she is sworn
to protect starring hayley atwell james
darcy and virgil kai and created by
christopher marcus and stephen mcfeely
critics say focusing on peggy carter as
a person first and an action hero second
makes marvel's agent carter a winning
stylish drama with bursts of excitement
and an undercurrent of cheeky fun
give me security
i need war shower in the chambers now
i think we might have a breach
i don't know
something ain't right
just get him down here
ugh
[Music]
hey you
you're not supposed to be in here
miss wendy
the powder room
is that way
oh i i'm so sorry i get really confused
around books
[Music]
and finally number one marvel's agents
of shield the worldwide law enforcement
organization known as shield employs an
elite team of agents who investigate
strange occurrences around the globe and
beyond its members each of whom brings a
specialty to the group work to protect
those who cannot protect themselves from
extraordinary and inconceivable threats
one of the major threats include a
formidable group known as hydra starring
clark gregg mignowen chloe bennett and
created by joss whedon jed whedon and
marissa tancheron critics say marvel's
agent of shield is sure to please comic
book fans but the strong ensemble and
brisk pacing helped to make this better
than average superhero show accessible
to non-fanboys as well
you don't get to decide who deserves to
die
i'm not the one who decides
oh
uh
[Music]
well my friends that about does it for
us be sure to stay tuned to the rotten
tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content you love until
next time i am your host naz perez and
we'll see you back here for more top 10s
on the rotten tomatoes countdown
[Music]
you